[Music]
one of the people I saw a lot of at the
Emmy Awards it was Milo Ventimiglia who
you gave your his big break to and my
girls don't cry do you watch this as I
know he was on Keros night he was a
heartthrob and yeah my look I'm so proud
of him yes I do watch this is us okay
kidding me I do live on this planet I
such an amazing show it's so great to
see him such a great actor and really
such a great guy
it was super fun shooting that video
because I got to you know have some of
the fun that Josh gets to have on his
movies of course I was totally just
nervous about the whole thing I didn't I
didn't know how to make out for camera I
just had to tell him like please help me
with this I'm gonna just try to be in
the moment if you could help me I don't
want to be thinking about where's the
light and where's the camera because
I'll just completely be hidden under
hair
[Music]
take a teacher he was so great he's a
nice guy he was yeah super great guy and
great actor